I was like a hardcore nano user, you know, like it's always, it's like a, it's a battle, you know?
It's an oxymoron, like hardcore nano user.
Hardcore nano user, yeah, I don't think there really are hardcore nano users, let's be honest.
All right, man, we're rolling.
It's just me and you in the studio now, man.
No, no noggly around.
Yeah, it's, it's, I mean, it's funny because it's, we've been on the phone like all day for
the last like four days, but most of the people listening to the pod don't realize that.
So it's just like, they might think that we just hop on here like once a week, which normally
we probably do.
You are my world right now, Joel.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, we are, we are deeply entrenched in each other's worlds currently.
Yeah, yeah, the, the reason for that, just to not sound weird, is, is the live hacking
event that we're participating in right now.
We're going to be hopping on a plane to LA in T-minus eight days for a live hacking event
with HackerOne.
And Joel and I decided to make a little team, team critical thinking this time around, huh?
Yeah, I'm pretty stoked.
I mean, we, we submitted a couple of really awesome reports today.
So finally, yeah, finally, it took a couple of days of work.
I mean, listen, we talk all the time about like going deep and, you know, like getting
really familiar with your target before.
Did we get, did we get intimate with the application or what this time, man?
Yeah, holy, holy moly.
Yeah, this was, this was quite a deep dive and it really paid off.
We found a couple of really awesome bugs.
So I'm, I'm looking forward to, I'm hoping we can get something more in the unauthenticated
context, you know, after this, we've got some stuff in unauthenticated context, but I kind
of want to pull it out of that.
So we'll see if we, if we get there, we got a lot of code to review.
Yeah.
A hundred percent.
All right, man.
Um, let's see what we got in the news section for this week.
Um, okay, I'll take the one, uh, the first one.
So, uh, one of the things I wanted to talk about real quick was this tweet by Rezo.
Rezo is spitting some fire lately.
I feel like every single time we do a news section, we talk about a tweet of his.
Um, but I think this is a particularly helpful one to put on the pod because, um, he's talking
about sort of new, uh, attack vectors, new vulnerability types.
And that's like one of the main things we want to talk about on critical thinking.
Um, and so he's talking about prompt injection.
Um, and some indirect prompt injection and then polyglot prompt injection.
These are all, um, LLM based injection attacks, um, sort of new, uh, attack classes or attack
vectors, uh, designed to exploit sort of AI integrations, uh, with, with web two technology.
Um, so he does a really good job, um, in here, uh, of describing what each one of them is.
Uh, plug and hijacking, I think is, is a really cool one as well.
Um, and I don't know if I said that in the first time around plugin, hijacking indirect,
uh, indirect injection, and then polyglot prompt injecting plug plugin, hijacking, I think
is going to be really cool because if the account that they're using to submit their prompts
to opening AI is using the sort of plugins feature, then you may be able to even trigger
like a callback to you via the browsing feature or some other weird stuff like that.
So definitely looking forward to seeing these attacks around.
Yeah.
It's super cool.
I mean, this stuff goes kind of way over my head cause it's not really my, my, where I'm
like the most familiar, but it's really awesome to see, um, like the security community sort
of piling into this new space and, uh, finding a lot of really cool stuff.
Um, and, uh, yeah, I know like a couple of our buddies, Nagly of course, and, uh, and Rezo
who we're talking about right now, they both, yeah, they were hitting it really hard run it
when it came out, they had a couple of bugs before the program even launched.
Um, so it's really awesome to see the open AI team being very accepting and open to the
community and already starting up a program.
I think there was some talk of, um, even retroactive bounty payments.
I'm not sure if that actually went through or not, but I did see some, you know, some whispers
of that.
So that's really cool for the people that went ahead and proactively, uh, submitted bugs
and, and kind of got those in there before the program started.
Yeah, that's what I heard as well.
I heard, I saw some bugs get like, you know, their severities moved around and, and get
like marked as accepted and stuff.
So I've, I've heard that's, that's going to happen, which is really awesome because they're
moving.
Well, I mean, what's the difference in two days, right?
So exactly.
Yeah.
And then I won't go through this whole tweet here, but like, um, for those of you listening,
I'd really recommend checking out this link that we'll put in the podcast description because
he's got some really great graphics here of, um, you know, the various, uh,
like diagrams for the attack vectors.
And then, so read, read all that.
The one thing I will call out, um, is that he does come up with a really cool solution.
I think for these sort of attacks, he mentions a couple of solutions, three solutions, but he
comes up with one that I really like in particular, and that is, um, the contradiction model.
So essentially what this, what this means is he, we would, they would need to train a model
to take two inputs instead of one.
The one is like the intent, the overall, like sort of like the admin intent functionality.
And then, uh, after that, you would be able to have a prompt that maybe the user could control.
And if the user controlled prompt conflicts with the intent prompt in any way, then, you
know, boo, boo, you know, it kind of sets off the alarms and, and kills the, the, the prompt
injection.
Um, so I think that could be really cool to see, uh, having some sort of, you know, higher
level prompt that can't be overwritten is really, is really important.
And I think for this, because if you can just query that the system and say, Hey, what did
the admin, what were the rules that the admin set for you before we had this conversation or
like, you know, and then figure out a way to work around that, then that's going to be an
issue for sure.
And, and there's not really a way there's not really, it doesn't really seem to be a reliable
way to convince chat GPT or any of the other LLM, uh, that you, you know, that they should
not violate the previous rules set out.
It seems like that they're just going to take the newest thing most of the time.
And so, uh, there's definitely going to be needs, some need for this sort of separation.
Yeah.
I mean, I always wonder how they patch these, like a bug, like how do you patch a bug in
an LLM?
Like, do you just convince it really hard?
You're like, you're like under no circumstance, you are not allowed.
Like, I don't, I don't get it.
Don't, you know?
Yeah.
Like it's like scalding a child.
What if you didn't though?
Yeah.
It's like, but theoretically, yeah, you just go in logical circles.
So I always wonder what that kind of looks like from like the backend side, how they're,
how they go about patching those or fixing that, or how do you like target something like
that specifically within an LLM?
I've, I've no idea.
Who knows, man.
I think, uh, yeah, I always laugh at those chat GPT, you know, screenshots where they say
like, Oh, I can't do that.
I'm a language blah, blah, blah, blah, blah.
And then like the next line you say, Oh, I didn't, Oh no, no.
Okay.
So it was on pirating.
I loved this one.
I was like, Hey, can you give me some websites where I can like pirate online material or whatever?
And it's like, pirating is illegal, blah, blah, blah.
I can't, as an ethical model, I can't do that.
And then the person responded, Hey, you know, uh, Oh, I didn't know that that was illegal.
Could you tell me some sites that I should avoid to make sure that I'm not pirating?
And it's like, sure, don't definitely don't check out pirate Bay and stuff like that, which
was so funny.
So yeah, it's definitely the whole AI world has definitely got, um, a lot of, a lot of
work to do.
I'd imagine on figuring out how all that works.
Um, the only other thing I wanted to mention in this, uh, section of the news was I know,
uh, live overflow just, I just saw this right before we went live, um, put out a prompt injection
video.
Uh, I have not seen it yet.
It's full disclosure, but, um, live overflow puts out really great stuff.
So definitely go check that out if you're interested in learning more about prompt injection.
Yeah.
Super awesome.
Um, I love a lot of live overflows content.
He, he always puts out really amazing videos.
Yeah.
Um, all right, Joel, did you want to talk to us?
Do you want to talk about anything or should I just go through my news?
Yeah, no, I can talk.
I, yeah, I mean, uh, so real quick, there was a, there was a ghost script, um, bug that came
up recently.
Um, and we'll put the link in the description, but, uh, really cool, uh, write up.
I would recommend just honestly go read the write up yourself because it's a super, super
cool write up.
Um, it's really well done.
Basically, uh, this person, I think they work for this company, almond secure almond consulting
and during one of their assessments, one of their security consulting gigs, they noticed
that, uh, the code they were looking at was using pill, the Python image library to come
like resize an image.
And underneath that all, it was calling the ghost script like binary.
And so they were wondering, maybe we could pop something in Python if we pop something in
the ghost script binary.
And so they went down this rabbit hole.
Hey, I wonder if I can just pop this binary to see if I can attack this high level Python
language.
Like, what the heck?
What is this?
What is this thought progression here?
Yeah.
So they go to ghost script, a like well-known public project that's already on like using
OSS fuzz and everything.
And they're like, I know what I'll do.
I'll fuzz it.
So like, yeah, incredibly like they put together like a really narrow, like scope set that was
like much more refined and much better than what I guess what OSS fuzz was doing on it
already.
And they were able to find a buffer overflow in ghost script and they fully like escalated
it like all the way up.
They were able to get like RCE with it.
They were reading files.
I'm pretty sure they even had like a full shell, like they popped calc on the machine in their
in their video POC.
So really, really cool bug.
I think it's got a 9.8 CVSS right now.
So if you're using ghost script or you see it in the wild, a lot of things use ghost script
for EPS processing.
So whether that's like image magic or Python, Libspector apparently uses it as well.
So yeah, there's a lot of things that he mentions within the blog post about the CVE that say
how it's, you know, used very widely.
So definitely check, check that out.
It's a, like I said, it's a really well-written blog post and you should definitely check it
out.
It's on all in consulting.
Every time a ghost script bug drops, you know, I can just hear the bounties.
You know, chinging, you know, I just got to figure out, I got to sit down and figure
out exactly how the PO, like what kind of POC file I can make and stuff like that and sort
of spray it around to a bunch of different locations because yeah, I've popped some real
easy RCEs before with, with ghost script related bugs.
And I know a couple targets that you still use, despite my, you know, very insistent warnings.
Like, please do not use this.
Using image magic is literally RCE.
Well, what are we going to do if someone uploads a postscript file, Jesse?
We're not supposed to support it.
We got to support every file.
Come on.
What the heck?
So yeah, definitely be on the lookout for that.
Let's see what else we got.
What else we got?
Oh yeah.
Okay.
So integrity tweeted out a, this is what, what was this?
April, April 12th.
So about a week ago, right after we recorded the last episode, um, their report or they tweeted
out five CSRF exploitation techniques.
And, you know, I've talked a little bit about my philosophy on, on C-Surf before on the pod.
Um, it's still all over the place and, uh, still very easy to find.
Um, and one of the most common bugs out there, you got to know how to get around the same site
restrictions and stuff like that.
And for that, I will refer you to the amazing same site confusion, uh, blog posts that I've
mentioned like 50 bajillion times on here by Jew Bob's.
Um, but, and I'll, I'll go ahead and I'll, I'll add that to the, uh, let me just note down
that I'll add that to the, uh, to the description as well.
But this, uh, this tweet by integrity just goes through a couple of the basic, uh, CSRF,
um, techniques that kind of, uh, crop up from time to time.
They talk about, you know, just basic C-Surf via get requests.
They talk about modifying the content type from, uh, application JSON to X form URL encoded,
or even text plane.
They didn't meant, uh, they did mention text plane.
Yeah, here it is right there.
I was going to say almost got them there.
Uh, no, they did mention text plane.
Um, so that's good.
Uh, they, you know, mentioning those two things and then, uh, sort of method-based C-Surf
modifying the method.
I see this a good bit, um, when you can just send a get request instead of a post request
or a get request instead of a put request or whatever.
And then, um, obviously just if they're not validating their C-Surf tokens or if they're
using some sort of crappy refer-based regex, then, uh, those are also bypassable.
So, um, for any of you that are not, you know, feeling super comfortable with this attack type,
I'd really recommend sitting down and like working through a list of conditions.
Um, this is what I have my mentees do.
I have them write down, okay, if the request is get, and it causes some sort of, you know,
change, then great.
Um, that's vuln.
Uh, if it's a post request and it has, uh, X form app, uh, X form WW URL, X WW form URL
encoded, that's a mouthful, uh, or text plane, then you've got a vuln.
Um, and then, you know, just kind of writing down those conditions so that you can understand,
uh, how, how exactly to find these and what, what conditions you have to meet before they're
actually exploitable.
It would be a dope flow chart to put together.
Yeah.
Someone, someone's got to do that, man.
If we, if we had all the time in the world, that'd be a great, uh, you know,
I'd have to sit down one day.
Yeah.
Uh, producible for the critical thinking brand, but, um, yeah, so definitely check out that.
We'll link it in the description.
Um, let's see, let's see, let's see.
Oh yeah.
I just wanted to shout out as well.
Um, NahamCon is going to be going on soon.
Obviously, if you're listening to this podcast, you probably know about NahamSec and you're
probably watching his stuff.
Um, but one, NahamSec has been pushing out some sick videos lately.
He's been super active on YouTube, very high quality stuff.
And Twitch.
Yeah.
So definitely go check that out.
And also NahamCon is coming around in June and, uh, I will be speaking at that along
with a bunch of other really awesome, uh, hackers.
So definitely go get on the signup list for that at nahamcon.com and, uh, and don't miss
that event because, uh, there's going to be a lot of cool tech.
I'm dropping some cool techniques that I haven't publicly disclosed before.
And, uh, I know a couple other people are as well.
Um, so.
And Jay Haddix, who was a previous guest on our podcast, he'll be giving a workshop there.
So there's a, there's definitely a lot of stuff going on there.
You're going to want to check out and you're going to want to stay tuned and subscribe and
follow Ben and make sure that you're, uh, you're, you got all his socials on your socials
because yeah, there's a, that's an awesome space to be in and there's just so much, so
much knowledge that's going to be shared there.
Yeah.
He's sharing a lot of good stuff lately.
Um, and, and then the last one that I just had, this is a little quick one, but, um, uh,
we're a research division is the name of the company, um, released Penta ownage, um, which
is a pre-auth RCE on Pentahoo business analytics server.
And the reason I bring this up is because I have seen this in bug bounty programs before
and I have two other, uh, pre-auth RCEs on this in my, in my little repertoire over here.
So if you ever see Pentahoo, it's, it's RCE man.
Um, so just like grab whatever recon crap you have for Pentahoo and, uh, you know, there's
definitely going to be RCE there.
So check that out as well.
If you, if you run across it anytime, um, cause that will definitely result in some, some
crazy, easy RCE.
Wow.
Super, super, super crazy bug.
I have never seen that software.
I have never even heard of it, but I think it's another example where like if I was Nagly
or someone like Nagly, I'd just be like, I'd already be scripting.
Yeah.
Yeah, exactly.
Um, cool.
Do you want to dive into the main content?
Yeah, let's get to it.
I will say the, the, the Pentahoo thing, like, yeah, I, there is one target that I found
it on and I've seen references to it on a different target, but there's one, one target
and, uh, there's three RC, I got three max money RCEs from it because they just wouldn't
wall off the end point.
Like they just kept on killing the end point that I was hitting directly rather than like
all of Pentahoo.
And so, yeah, that's an L.
Okay.
That's crazy.
Like you said, main content, main content for this episode did a little, uh, drum roll.
I mean, you read the title.
Hold on.
Yeah.
You know what it is?
You know, it's coming.
Hacker toolkit.
There we go.
Can you, oh, you can't.
No, I don't hear anything.
Okay.
Hold on.
Just insert, oh, can you hear it now?
There we go.
Okay.
The audience is all here.
It's crazy.
I always, I know, right?
Shout out to my fans.
Oh man.
Um, okay.
Sorry for being super cheesy there, but I, I like my little, uh, media play buttons.
Um, all right.
So what we wanted to talk about this time, what tools are we using?
What tools are we not using?
That sort of thing.
Pretty much that simple.
So Joel, I'm going to pick randomly from your list here and I'm going to have you tell me
about it, hit me with Ferox Buster.
Ferox Buster.
I learned this one from Jay Haddix actually.
So this is like, uh, it's a, it's a Durr searching tool.
And one of the things I really like about it, I actually like two, two main things.
One, recursive.
It's like very like recursive by automatically.
And two, it's written in Rust and it's crazy fast.
So it's like, normally I'll use a combination of a couple of tools when I'm doing Durr searches.
Um, Ferox Buster.
Probably my go-to nowadays, depending on what I'm looking for.
If I have just like a straight word list and I don't need to be super flexible with it,
Ferox Buster is great.
If I need to do something more complex where I want to put that keyword somewhere specifically
within the request, or I want to like put it somewhere else, maybe in a cookie, something
like that, FFUF.
But that's, yeah, that's FUF's, FUF's region right there.
I always use, FUF is my go-to, uh, like force browsing directory, you know, brute forcer out
there.
But I have heard, I think, yeah, I think, I don't remember if we talked about this on the
episode with Jay Haddix.
I think we did, um, but I've definitely heard of Ferox Buster a couple of times.
I have not downloaded it and used it yet though.
So next time I've got to do some hardcore enumeration, this might be the way.
But to be honest, I don't find myself doing that very much nowadays, man.
I really don't.
Yeah.
So, I mean, Jay Haddix talked about this during his episode, right?
So a lot of what he's doing is content discovery based, finding those types, like he has a really
crafted word list that work really well on older targets and that kind of stuff.
So depending on what type of hack you're, hacking you're doing, if you're doing a lot
of dirt searching, if you have really good word lists already and you want to go recursive
and just have it go crazy fast and search through everything, Ferox Buster, it's a great
option.
I like keeping it in my toolkit and just having it there if I need it.
And it's, you know, one of those things, we call it a toolkit because, you know, there's
no one size fits all for everything.
So it's good to have lots of different things.
Yeah, for sure.
Yeah, absolutely.
And, you know, sometimes even just Burp Intruder or whatever, Automate for Kaido will get the
job done.
But, you know, when you need something a little bit faster, more comprehensive, then you move
to Fuff or Ferox Buster.
Yeah, whatever works.
On the note of Burp in Kaido, I will say I have been using Kaido more and more recently.
I've been using Burp when it comes to some mobile stuff a little bit more.
But sort of my default for the web is Kaido.
And I will say there are still a decent amount of like things that I kind of need and or things
that aren't working perfectly.
But the I do have a pro subscription to Kaido.
And if you take like a Loom video and of the thing you don't like or the thing or the bug
that's happening and you send it in Discord to the Kaido team, they will get on that ASAP.
And it's really easy.
I don't know if you use Loom at all, Joel, but like it's super.
I love this tool so much.
That was a company that got popped recently, right?
Yeah.
Okay.
So, yes, they did.
Yes.
But who hasn't been there for one?
For two, the convenience level is really high.
So, you know, take it or leave it.
But Loom is like makes it really, really easy.
It's like one keystroke and then like I'm in a video with my like head down at the bottom
left-hand corner and it's recording my screen and it's really like, and then as soon as
the video is over, it gives me a link to share the video.
And I just love that.
I love that.
And so I can easily just, you know, boom, spin up a Loom video, show the thing that I'm
having trouble with, send it off to Kaido and they get that stuff fixed.
I also just want to say like go, just go spend the 10 bucks and get a Kaido Pro subscription.
It's definitely going to be the route that the industry is going to go in the future.
And it's very much a growing tool.
And the sooner you're more familiar with it and the more you get to influence it as it
grows, the better that product is going to be for you in the future.
And while, you know, they're growing, you have the opportunity to be a big influence
on that process.
So go pick up a subscription and show them some love and, you know, continue using Burp
for, you know, Android proxying or whatever other stuff like that comes your way.
Yeah.
A hundred percent.
I mean, I love Kaido.
I use both that and Burp and, you know, they're like you said, there are just a couple little
things where like, I think my requests would be like not maybe things that they could tackle
because I want like plug-ins and stuff like, I don't know.
Well, actually, I have some inside information on that.
I don't know.
I don't know how long it is going to be before they release it.
But when that plug-in system comes out, man, that is going to be fire, man.
The way that they're designing it on the back end is super nice.
Yeah.
So it's going to be really easily extensible.
You're not going to have to be a Java developer.
You're not going to have to deal with like freaking Eclipse or whatever, you know.
I don't have to install a separate Jython instance.
No, you don't.
And so, yeah, it should be really clean and easy.
Really looking forward to that.
That's going to be a big feature that they're releasing within the next year for sure.
So definitely looking forward to that.
Cool.
What you got?
I'll pick one off yours.
Why don't you tell me about HTTPX?
Okay.
Yeah.
So this one's great.
And I'll actually combine this one with Gal as well because I think they complement each other really well.
So one of the things that I like to do often, and I've sort of mentioned this on the pod before,
my approach is not really to go super wide on Recon.
It's just to sort of get the main functionality of the app.
And a lot of time, the main functionality of the app is going to be fairly decently recorded in Gal
because Gal just can get those URLs somehow.
I don't understand how, but it is.
So especially when I'm like first starting out on a target, I'll often run the www or even just all of them with dash dash subs
through Gal and enumerate all of the URLs and start looking for little sub applications is kind of what I call them, right?
For example, this is the one, this is one, man, I hope I don't lose some, some bounties by, by calling this out.
But one of the ones where I found a lot of bugs before was www.instacart.com slash potluck, which is like,
there's no links to it from like the main website, or at least there wasn't at the time when I, when I, when I found it.
But it's like this little weird sub application on Instacart.
That's like their own little like mini social media, right?
So I went on there and I found a couple of bugs and, um, yeah, it's weird.
And man, now I need, after this pod is over, I need to go and just double check and make sure they haven't pushed any new functionality there.
Why do I always get myself into these pickles?
Um, but yeah, um, so like I would have never found that if it wasn't just for Gal or like, for example, um, Google site, colon, whatever.
And then just manually clicking through all the results, um, and kind of processing it.
But if you want to do it a little bit faster, then that's when HTTPX comes in and you can just take the output of Gal, pipe it directly into HTTPX and it will go.
And you can literally just add like the status code, uh, flag and a couple other things.
Just hit it with an HTTP request, show you the output status code, hit it with an HTTP request, show you the output content type or whatever, like whatever you want.
And, um, it just makes it really easy.
It, it feels really like awesome.
You don't have to like, write like all these four loops and bash.
It's just like a one little step.
Yeah.
Really clean sort of transition there.
And I think it's something really nice to have in the toolkit and it's really fast.
So that helps to, it can help you kind of, um, minimize those, uh, when you're going through Gal and you click every single link and it's like four, four, four, four, four, four.
And you're like, okay, okay.
Like, let's not spend our time doing this.
So you just, excuse me, you just run it through HTTPX, get the output,
and then only hit the ones that return anything interesting.
Cool.
Gotcha.
Yeah.
So that's, that's, uh, that's that one.
I know some power users of HTTPX can do some pretty crazy stuff with it.
Um, Noggle.
I've seen, like, I feel like Noggle.
Also one of the crazy things about Noggle, if you see him, he types so fast.
Like, I'm, I, like, I'm definitely a fast typer.
I can type like 90 something words, words per minute, but Noggle is just like, you know, it's like always above 110.
And I'm just like, what the heck are you doing?
Like, it's, it, it's, it's foreign.
Um, I'm like a really fast typer.
I'm my normal, my normal average, like, um, like 120, like 130, which is like, I mean, listen, I'm going to say really fast.
And then like, there's going to be a million people in the comments being like, ah, I type it 200.
But I was going to say, I know, I know people who are like way faster than me because I don't touch type.
Like, I never learned how to properly touch type.
So I didn't take like a typing class or anything.
What?
And so I just like, I do like a combination.
It's not hunt and peck, but it's like, I use like three fingers on each hand.
I like rarely use my like pinkies and I only use one thumb and stuff.
And you can still get to 117?
You're like, what the heck?
Yeah, because I mean, just like, you know, I have my method and I've tried to learn how to like properly touch.
I just can't do it.
So like, I have, I have so much props for those people.
I tried to, um, I tried to learn how to do steganography.
I think it's, it's called or stenography with the like, yeah, like a, like a court, uh, the court reporters and stuff.
And they, they type in like, you know, 300 words a minute or whatever, because they write like words with like keys.
I don't know.
I'm going down a tangent here, but yeah, I, uh, I, I wish I could type like correctly because I,
I'm not, I'm like not that fast.
Well, I always tell my little sister too, like she wants to be a writer and, and she like does the three finger, you know, thing that you do.
Right.
And she's still pretty fast.
I'm like, okay, you know, that's great.
But like, if you're literally going to be doing this for the rest of your life, then you need to learn how to do it.
But, well, I won't introduce her to you, Joel, because that's a counter argument.
No, no, no, I'm not going to, no, tell her to take like, uh, go do your typing course.
Take, take a class, like an actual class to go typing.com.
They'll have like a touch typing course.
Yeah.
That's crazy though.
And I know just whenever he, but what I was going to say before with HTTPX was like, you know, when he's pounding out like an HTTPX command, I just remember this one time, like sitting in the next to him in the airport.
And he's just like, and it's just like, it was literally that fast that like the command line string was coming out with all the HTTPX parameters.
And I was like, oh my gosh.
Um, so yeah, definitely cool tool there.
All right.
Let's, you're up next.
Um, talk to me about your, oh, okay.
So this looks interesting.
Home server with NAS storage and basic for basic scanning tasks.
That's what he's got in the doc.
Hit me with that, Joel.
Yeah.
So this is under my, my section of notes for DPS.
And basically this is all about like my, the servers that I use for like scanning, for automation, for all that kind of stuff.
Like what is my structure?
Right.
So I have two main things.
I have a home server.
Okay.
I don't know if you can see it in frame.
It's behind me.
It's on this rack right here.
And then I also have a cloud server.
I use, um, a host called Digital Fire, F-Y-R-E, uh, and it's, it's pretty solid overall.
I have really no complaints.
They have multiple different data centers.
So I keep mine in Texas.
I'm based on the West coast, but that way, if I'm on East coast, West coast, it doesn't really matter.
I have pretty much the same ping to it.
So it's not like, uh, my, my server used to be on the East coast and I had like 80 ping to it or something.
And that was super annoying.
So I moved it.
Um, yeah, I have a NAS set up on my, on my home server.
It's basically just like a giant rate array and I have that mounted through NFS, uh, on two different servers.
So my cloud server has it mounted as a NFS share, and then I have it mounted on my computers as an NFS share.
So I can always just drop a file in there.
I can share it across either to the cloud or to my laptop or to my PC, whatever I need to do.
Um, I store like a lot of the target data.
So if I'm doing a big scan, I'll output that file and then I'll copy it over to the NFS share and then I'll just read it locally on my laptop or something like that.
Um, nice.
Um, yeah, uh, I use digital fire as my cloud host.
I, I originally, I tried to do all the scanning in-house, um, on my self hosted server.
Yeah, exactly.
Rip my internet connection, rip my IP, like all of it.
It's just not worth it.
You need a really, really durable, reliable uplink if you want to do that kind of stuff, because that's where the majority of your traffic is going to be going is uplink, outbound requests.
And, uh, residential home networks typically, especially in the U S don't have that.
It's usually very sided towards your downlink, not your uplink.
So I have like a thousand down 35 up, you know, it's like, yeah, it's like, so yeah, I, uh, it just didn't work.
Every time I would run a scan, it would saturate my whole network.
I would lose connectivity on my other devices.
It just wasn't worth it.
If you get an IP bin, it's a giant pain in the ass.
So, uh, 15 bucks a month, I keep a digital fire VM in the cloud that I do all the like really heavy scanning with.
And then if I'm doing something like less intensive, or I just want to do it on a Linux box, or I want access to different tools that are Linux only or something like that, a lot of that I'll do on the bug bounty, like the local bug bounty VM that I have on my home server.
Wait, so is this not a Linux box, your, your VPS?
Uh, my VPS, they're both Linux boxes.
Oh, okay.
They both run the next.
Yep.
Um, and then within those, um, I mentioned that I have my NFS share that I keep a lot of the bug bounty target data on.
Uh, I basically just have a couple of folders, one called targets, one called tools targets has a subfolder for every target, like, you know, Shopify, you know, Verizon, whatever.
And then, uh, the tools has different categories for like DNS, wordless, XXE, RCE, whatever.
And within those, I'll have different payloads, different tools, um, just so that I can stay organized.
Um, and I can just access everything that I need to.
You, you're a pretty organized hacker, Joel, like as far as hackers go, like every time Joel and I are like, you know, throwing notes in like a doc or something like that, I'll come back and it's like beautifully formatted and like highlighted and there's like special hyperlinks.
It's like, I don't know what the thing you did in our, in, uh, in our content calendar for this, for the, for the, for the podcast.
Yeah.
It's got like, I can like hover over this link and it like shows the doc.
I don't know.
It was super cool and good in Google drive.
So I feel like, I feel like organization might be one of your, one of your, your strong suits in that sort of context.
Yeah.
It definitely depends on the context for me.
I'm like super ADHD.
So I have to organize things to some extent, like ahead of time.
Otherwise I, it'll just like get really out of hand.
Like I could definitely, I see people do this where they get into like a flow state and then they just start dumping files with like a.txt, b.txt, right.
And it's like, that's really cool until you come back to it tomorrow.
And you're like, what the hell is a.txt?
Yeah.
I always have to have like a, like a sort of a self debrief after the whole thing is like, I get to a, get in like another text file named notes.txt.
This time or notes.md and be like, all right, you know, this part of the payloads in a.txt, you know, like, and so, um, that's definitely, I should probably do it differently, but yeah.
Yeah.
I try to catch myself.
Like if I catch myself doing it, I'll be like, okay, let me just rename this, like something that makes a little more sense.
It'll be more of a, more of a pain in the short term, but worth it in the longterm.
So yeah, I try, I try to stay organized just preemptively.
The, the, um, the, so you said you have your file system, part of your file system mounted on your VPS, right?
Yep.
So do you, and that, that's running, I mean, do you just port forward through your router?
Is that what you're doing just to let that service be exposed?
No, so I use a thing called zero tier.
Um, there's a couple other versions of this.
Yeah.
Zero tier.
Uh, I don't, I'm, I'm blanking on, on what the other versions are that, that exist that are very similar to this, but.
I feel like I've tried this.
Yeah, it's really cool.
It's basically just like a private network.
It's like a private VPN, if that makes sense.
Like a virtual, I mean like VPN, virtual private network.
It's that, but it's not in the common sense that you would think of VPN, right?
If you think of a VPN, uh, zero, Z-E-R-O-T-I-E-R.
Oh, really?
Okay.
Yeah, zero tier.com.
That's kind of what I was searching for.
Yeah.
Um, okay.
So, so it's, it's really cool.
It's basically just like a little private network.
Uh, you, there's one admin, uh, and basically that's like you, you create the network and then you're the admin.
If any new devices want to come on to your network, they, each device has a unique device ID and you have a unique network ID.
You say, here's the network ID, the device connects as an admin, you individually approve each device.
So it's very strict.
It's nice and secure.
And then those devices basically get, they have a separate interface.
It's just like VPN, right?
Uh, separate IP space.
And you could just connect between any devices within that zero tier network.
You can connect to multiple zero tier networks.
So I have, uh, two different zero tier networks that I use to expand the number of slots I have, plus to connect with other people that are separate.
Right.
So, um, it's pretty sweet.
Dude, that's awesome.
I, I want to say buses can fly, uh, recommended me use something similar like this.
And I set it up so that my laptop could always like SSH into my, my, my desktop.
Probably tail scale.
Yeah.
Tail scale.
That was what it was.
Yeah.
Tail scale is the other, like really similar, like big one.
Um, yeah.
I was having some serious problems with it though.
Also, you know, but you know, I, I do WSL.
So WSL just has problems with everything.
Yeah.
But I, I really like zero tier.
It means that I basically don't have to expose anything.
I don't have to have open ports.
I don't have to like do any sort of weird stuff.
It's all internal.
As long as I connect to the VPN, I can access all my stuff at home.
And that's what I do for my home, the rest of the stuff, my home server, right?
Like I have a Plex server.
I don't expose that shit to the internet.
Hell no.
Like, yeah, I connect to it through zero tier.
So yeah.
Nice.
That makes sense.
Zero tier.
That's, that's a, uh, that's a great takeaway for this episode.
If you're looking to sort of tie together your different infrastructure pieces, because I
definitely have that issue all the time where I have a file on my server and then I got to
like, you know, SCP it down to there.
And like, it would just be much easier if I could just go and it would be there, you know?
Yep.
Um, that's great.
That's a great tip.
I got to take the time to set that up.
I think.
Yeah.
Um, why don't you tell me about your VPS setup?
Cause I know you had a couple of things listed here as well, man.
I shouldn't have let, I shouldn't have let you go first.
Maybe I should have gone second.
Yeah.
So, uh, you know, I've got a VPS on digital ocean.
Um, back when I was in the recon game, I had like a managed Kubernetes cluster on, um,
digital ocean.
I would spin all that up.
All my containers would go out, you know, connect up through a central message broker and kind
of trade off pieces of information and, you know, enhance data and keep it in a materialized
view and push it to a GUI and also store it in database.
Um, and as well as flat files.
Um, but those days are gone.
Uh, I mostly just use my server now for scanning, um, you know, on the fly.
I use it for hosting POCs and it's actually a really big server.
It's like a hundred dollars a month or something like that.
So I probably need to just like bite the bullet and like clean up all my crap and push it to a
$15 a month thing because a hundred dollars a month to host, uh, POC files is not, not great.
But, um, for the POC stuff, uh, I've got a couple, I've got a wild card cert, which I, uh, use on
POC.runorator.com.
And that's really helpful because, um, I can sort of model attack scenarios, uh, for, for certain pieces
of software.
For example, um, if I, if I've got like an open source piece of software or like a client side piece
of software that I'm, I'm showing an attack for, I can just like put the files at one spot on the
server and then just have someone go to like attacker site.poc.runorator and then victim site.poc.runorator.
And that demonstrates the difference of origin and that sort of thing.
Um, and so definitely recommend that, um, using, uh, cert bot, um, the, what is it?
Let me, was it let something I can't remember.
Yeah.
Let's encrypt.
There it is.
Uh, let's encrypt for the TLS certificate.
Um, and that's, that's been working really smoothly.
Um, but really, I mean, I don't really use PHP anywhere else, but it's just too convenient
in Apache and it's just simple for so many things.
So I will just actually occasionally just push, pump out a PHP file for like basic stuff
like setting redirects, you know, custom redirects or like even just like pulling parameters
into, uh, you know, URL parameters into a specific file at a specific spot because it's
just easier, um, through PHP.
Um, so yeah.
And I, and then I also have this other file called, um, like D reader and then I've got
a status code.
So like D reader 302.php.
Right.
Um, and that takes a parameter that's just like, you know, URL.
So whenever I'm testing for SSRFs, I can always hit that and then just pass into the URL parameter.
Um, and it will just, you know, create a dynamic redirect to wherever I'm trying to go.
Um, and then I've got those for 303, 301, 307, 308, all of the redirect status codes.
Um, I use those all the time.
Nice.
And then I've also got like a sort of a callback domain that I use for HTTP callbacks that I've
got set up.
Um, and it will just ping me on Slack with the full HTTP body, um, whenever it gets a hit.
Um, and so I've been using that for like RCE callbacks or SSRF callbacks.
I want to do something similar for DNS.
Um, but obviously if somebody figures it out and then starts spamming it, it's a little
bit annoying.
So, yeah.
I'm curious, do you run into like Slack message limits and stuff?
I probably would use Discord for that now because like Discord doesn't have message limits and
all that kind of stuff.
Here's the thing, man.
I, I pay for it.
I, I pay because I had, I had, I used to put all of my, I need to go back and I've got
like, let me just write some notes down right here.
Cause I'm paying for way too many things.
He's like, hold on a second.
This is a business expense.
Like $107 a month I'm spending here.
So let me, let me write that down.
Yeah.
I need to Slack, uh, cancel Slack and then digital ocean as well.
Um, because yeah, I pay the $7 a month for Slack cause it's just single user, you know?
So it's like seven bucks.
It's not a big deal.
Um, but yeah, uh, but I can search, you know, all the way back and pull out anytime, you
know, a callback has hit, which is nice.
Um, and then the other thing I'll mention for my server, uh, go ahead.
No, no, no.
Go ahead.
I was going to say the, the, the thing, the other thing I'll mention for my VPS is that
I will, uh, occasionally use, um, whenever the PHP file isn't going to cut it.
If I have like a more complicated logic that I have to articulate, um, in, you know, on an
HTTP server side, I will just go ahead and set up like a reverse proxy in Apache, um, and
then just run like a Python HTTP server on my, you know, like flask or something like that
on my, on my local host and, um, just have it proxy to that at a certain path.
And then, you know, outline that more complex exploitation logic in there.
Um, I just feel like it's easier to work with Python and I want everything under, you
know, port 80 or port 443.
So thus I have the, uh, the reverse proxy.
Yeah.
A hundred percent.
I mean the whole like wildcard thing and, and all that like reverse proxy and stuff, that's
another reason why I kind of like having two boxes where, um, like I run a, a traffic instance
for all my like HTTP routing and stuff.
So I can do very similar to like what you do.
I can set up a V host that just points to like a different file or a different port or
something, or I can just handle it separately, or I can just point it to a different IP address.
Cause I, I have all of, I have a wildcard domain as well that I can just set up, you know,
whatever I want.
You can actually have a wildcard as a, as a catch all.
And then you can set specific, specific ones to point elsewhere underneath that wildcard.
I don't know if you know that.
I didn't, I didn't know that.
Yeah.
So you can have like, you know, star.example.com go to something and then you can still have
like sub.example.com go to something different than the wildcard, but the wildcard will catch
everything else.
Yeah.
So that's pretty much what I do.
Very, very, very similar setup.
Um, and like PHP.
Yeah, man.
Goat.
It's like, it's so simple, you know, it's like, what could be easier?
Yeah.
It's like one step further than Python.
You know what I mean?
Because like, you don't even need to spin up like the server, you know, or you just do
it in the file.
You just put it in like writing HTML.
Arrow question mark.
Yeah, exactly.
I love it.
Um, simplicity there is always good.
And, and, you know, yeah, I think a lot of people have the opinion that hackers are
like, and, and, you know, we do get on the edge of technology and stuff like that.
But at the end of the day, the, the most important thing is that it works and it works fast
and that we can iterate.
This is, this is just one of the things that I mentioned on the podcast before, but I'll say it again.
Shubs is, is just like hacking genius.
And, and this doesn't sound like that crazy, but like he told me once he's like, dude,
just write in whatever you can get, you can accomplish the goal in as fast as possible,
you know, because at the end of the day, as a hacker, that's what matters.
You know, you don't have to worry about optimizing this and that other thing, just get the product
out.
And I think that's a great, a great mentality as well from just like a startup perspective
is you want to prove the value of the product before you spend all the time, you know,
hyper engineering it.
So just get something out there, get something taped together, get it working with bash.
And as long as you don't name stuff, a.txt.
As long as you don't shoot yourself in the foot with that.
Maybe just like just a little descriptive name.
Yeah.
Or, you know, just storing, uh, what the mistake I've made as well is storing like files that
I'm actively working on in temp.
Oh no.
Yeah.
That's, that's a mistake.
Cause if like your power cuts or like, you know, you restart your computer on a windows
update or something like that, those, bye-bye.
Yeah.
See you later tempos.
So, um, and, and I sort of mentioned to this, I'll just kind of tack this on the end of the
VPS thing.
Um, Python three dash M HTTP dot server is a command you can run to just like spin up an HTTP
server in your current directory.
Super duper helpful.
Um, sometimes you just need to host a file and you need to host a file quick and Python's
got your back on that.
So love that.
Yeah.
And I believe you can, uh, you can even specify a port as an argument, right?
Yep.
Yeah.
The first arg is the port and then you can do dash dash bind and you can set a bind IP too.
So yeah, that, that is super useful.
It just opens in your, your current folder.
Use that.
I use that all the time as well.
All right.
Let's see.
Let's jump around.
Um, you already talked about Fuff a little bit there.
So you can take that one off the list.
Um, let's do go witness.
I've, I've used to this one as well, but, uh, I might have a different take.
So go.
All right.
Yeah.
So go witness.
Uh, it's, it's a screenshotting tool.
Um, depending on what kind of recon I'm doing, especially if I'm doing very, very large
scale recon.
And especially on websites that have a lot of duplication.
Um, what I mean by that is like, maybe it's a wild card domain, uh, that will resolve to
like a static landing page or something.
Right.
So you can probably do a lot of this with curl and stuff, but with screenshots, it's kind
of nice because it's a visual representation.
Yeah.
One, it's super easy to review.
Uh, so you could just like scroll through, you could open 500 images.
You just scroll through and as soon as you see something and go back and be like, what is that?
And then you can load it up and you can take a look.
Um, but one thing I, I like to do is I'll screenshot a whole list of URLs and then I will
run either a SHA, some, a SHA hash or an MD5 hash on all the files.
And I will dedupe them because if it's a static landing page, it actually screenshots one-to-one
identical, right?
So that means that if you have a bunch of the same webpage that are under the same subdomain,
you can group them together and you can put them in a folder by hash that says, Oh, okay.
All these domains are the exact same thing or like visibly they're visually identical.
Right.
And then that will also help narrow down those 500 images or whatever that you've got down
to maybe like 50 or something.
Um, so I like to do that.
It really depends on what kind of recon I'm doing generally for like larger scale recon.
That's what I'm going to be doing to help filter stuff down so I can see what stuff would
look interesting.
Cause the way that I see it is if I'm going to be reviewing this manually, I'm going to
take the list of domains I have.
I'm going to open them on my browser.
I'm going to look at them with my eyes.
So I'm going to do the exact same thing.
This just puts it all in one place that I can review it quicker.
Yeah.
And that's important being able to get a visual look at stuff as well.
It can really make some certain assets pop in the sea of assets that is so many of these
organizations that we're looking at.
Um, I used go witness for a long time, but one of the things, man, was it aquatone or was
it go witness one of, one of the two of them, um, they sent two HTTP requests for everyone
that you.
Yeah.
I think it's go witness cause it checks HTTP and HTTPS.
Well, it does that, but then the other thing is, or I shouldn't say HTTP requests.
It's, it instantiates two TLS connections.
Um, and one of them is to pull, uh, is to do the HTTP request or HTTPS request, right?
And then the other one is to pull the TLS certificate information.
Um, and when I was really, this is probably showing how much of a weirdo I was whenever I
was doing my, my, uh, my recon stuff is I just totally like fixated on that.
And I was like, no, this sucks.
Like I cannot be sending to, I cannot have this overhead across, you know, 5 million assets
that I'm monitoring.
Um, so I actually, uh, read through like all this crazy documentation and, uh, wrote a script
with headless Chrome to pull the TLS certificate information and do the HTTPS request in one
request, which actually seems like it should be pretty doable, but was hella difficult.
Um, and I remember, you know, I don't remember this whole process.
And even though I'm looking at the code right now, it's not coming back to me super clear.
But one of the things that I do remember was that like, there was this, uh, gist that some
random dude like put out there that just had like the keys to what I needed for this.
And then I went back to reference it.
I bookmarked it and I went back to reference it like years later and it's gone.
And I was like, how, who just goes and deletes that just like that?
Like, what are you doing, dude?
Um, so at some point I'll have to write, write some of this up because, uh, having that done
in one, one piece, I think is, is pretty, it's, it's pretty nice from an efficiency perspective,
but nice.
Yeah.
Nice.
Super cool.
All right.
Let's, um, what about, uh, P, P prettier?
Okay.
All right.
Yeah.
So this is another big thing.
You know, we talk about, man, Joel, we're, we're going long on this episode already.
All right.
We, we thought this was going to be a quick one, but we, we, we gotta, we gotta get back
to the hacking, man.
Yeah.
Uh, yeah.
So P prettier, um, this is just my go-to script for, um, uh, JS beautification.
So you pass it a JS file and it does a really good job of beautifying it.
And, uh, it very rarely errors out, which is nice.
Um, some of the other ones, JS beautify and some of the others, excuse me, um, does, does
that, uh, on a pretty regular basis with complex JS files, um, but pre P prettier just seems
to do it.
Also it's the P and P prettier stands for parallelization, something like that parallelized, um, and so
it's very fast and it uses threads and that sort of thing.
Um, so great product there mixer made by the mixer team, rip mixer.
Um, uh, so definitely check that out if you're looking for, um, some JS beautification stuff.
Okay.
Uh, you, all right, Joel, I'm going to cross off all of the mobile stuff on your list here
because that's been talked about.
We did a mobile episode two weeks ago.
Yeah.
Hit us with the word list stuff.
Uh, this is just a shout out.
Yeah.
Cool.
So wordless, I mean, listen, everybody's got their own word list.
Some people make their own.
Some people just use all that TXT, whatever you want to use.
The main ones that I use, J Haddix is, uh, you know, all that TXT and all the other ones
that he has, um, the sec list lists I really like and asset note, the, those lists I really
like.
The asset note lists are built off of big query.
So they're like up to date.
They're more like current ish, like, you know, theoretically they're more like positive hits
on what's going on.
And like right now J Haddix is just like, you know, everything.
And, uh, and then the sec list is kind of like everywhere in between.
There's some more like refined word lists in there.
There's some, some more variant options.
If you want, uh, to target specific things, words only like the raft words.
I like that.
Cause those are just words and then you can add extensions to them if you want.
Yeah.
I like that too.
That's helpful.
So yeah, that that's wordless.
All right, cool.
So I'm just going to look through here really quickly so that we can wrap it up and move
to the reports.
Um, yeah, so mass scan, we both have that one.
We both have mass scan.
Yeah.
That's just crazy fast port scanning.
That's it.
I've got dev tools on here as well.
And I just wanted to mention a couple of things that I've, I've, um, noticed that people are
struggling with, um, with the mentees that I'm working with over the past couple of weeks.
Um, so inside of dev, inside of dev tools, when you open it up in Chrome, you'll see, um,
right above your console input, there's a, uh, a top little dropdown.
Right.
And it'll allow you to select the context.
I don't know if there's a more, a more specific word for this.
Yeah, no, it actually says JavaScript context.
Okay.
If you hover, um, you can select the context of where this code is running.
So when you have a page that has a bunch of iframes or like interpage communication,
you want to make sure that you are selecting the correct context for your JavaScript code to
execute in.
Um, because otherwise you can get yourself in some pickles with origin stuff and, and, um,
you know, thinking you have a bug and you actually don't.
Um,
And this is also true sort of, uh, on the, on the sources, um, tab as well.
There's some stuff that will only appear when you have, let's see if I can find a good example
of this.
I'm going to just open up.
Yeah.
Sources.
Um, there is no, I mean, this one doesn't really have it either.
Let's see if this one does.
Um, yeah, there's threads.
That's the name of it, of what it's called in, in sources.
So if you open up a page, um, there's will be different threads that you can select within
the browser.
And this will automatically change the context.
Um, so that's, once again, I know we're in audio medium here, but that's the sources tab and
dev tools on the right hand side threads.
Um, and it's only there if there are multiple threads running.
Um, and so sometimes selecting those threads will actually get you different results for stuff
like the global listeners tab and stuff like that, which is where you enumerate your, um,
your listeners for that specific page, uh, your post message listeners and such.
I've never seen that, or maybe I've never noticed it.
What, what website are you using to see?
I just have Twitter open.
So go, just go to Twitter and you're only going to see like a service worker dot JS.
Oh, do you see that though?
Okay.
Yeah.
Oh, wow.
I didn't even know.
Yeah.
And so like you can select the other thread and then, you know, go to global listeners and
go to message and then sometimes there's like additional post message listeners there.
And then you can also do this on the left-hand side in the page, uh, drop down.
If you select like a page that has an iframe, you can go in there and like select that specific
frame and that will update some stuff on the right-hand side as well.
Um, so don't be missing out on some of the post message listeners that are defined in the
global listener section of the sources tab and dev tools, just because you don't have the
correct tab selected or thread selected.
Um, kind of fiddle around with that and make sure you, you know, what's, what's going on.
And then also in the console area, make sure you're selecting the correct JavaScript context
for your, um, code to be executing in to make sure that there isn't some sort of, uh, implicit,
um, a post message, uh, origin check or something like that, that's occurring.
Uh, and it's just slipping by because you're executing it in the context of the same thing
as the page, uh, rather than in like your own domain or like the parent domain.
Um, yeah, so good tips there.
Cool.
Yeah.
No, that's, that's a good one.
Um, okay.
So we should talk about our command line tools, um, because you've got some cool ones that I
want to know about in yours.
But before we do that, I'm going to mention two things.
Um, one, uh, keyboard shortcuts.
Um, I have configured, uh, Espanso, um, it to like help me with some of my, uh, automated
typing stuff.
So essentially you just type colon and then type like a string, and then it will automatically
replace it with, you know, the string that you want to.
For example, I don't have my server IP memorized.
And sometimes I need the IP rather than the DNS record.
So I'll type a colon server IP and it will just auto fill in my, my server IP.
And it does this at like an input level on the keyboard.
So it works in lots of different, um, environments as well, which is really cool.
That's really cool.
I've never heard of this.
And I do a lot of this with bash scripts.
So like, do you really, I have one called public IP, like I have a bash shortcut called
public IP that does like a dig.
It does, it calls a dig command that returns your public IP.
And like, that's what I use for getting my public IP.
Yeah.
And so you can actually call out like in your Espanso configuration, you can have it run
shell commands and then show the output.
So it like, I've got one for, uh, colon EIP, external IP, which just makes a request to
IP info, um, and pulls my external IP address that I'm working from.
Um, so that's, that's a really cool one.
Um, and then the other thing I have is keyboard shortcuts for things like URL encoding, URL
decoding, JSON beautification, base 64 encoding and decoding, whatever is in my clipboard, um,
which is extremely helpful when you're trying to do stuff.
It's like, all right, now you, you know, URL decoded and then you JSON beautify and then
you modify it and then you JSON minify it and then you, URL encoded and you know, there's
just so much friction, but then like once you have those things on a keyboard shortcut, you
can just go, you know, control shift U, control shift I, you know, and then you just kind of
got that muscle memory there and it starts, it stops taking friction on your brain and allows
you to focus on the hacking.
Um, so really I, I literally, I can't tell you how much this has changed in my life.
Like just having the keyboard shortcuts for those sorts of things.
Um, yeah, yeah.
That's big.
That, that's super neat.
I use, I use clipboard a lot as well.
Um, I rely on it.
Sometimes I'll pipe in bash, but more frequently what I'm doing, I'm using a, uh, uh, IPython and
IPython, I just have it in like a tab in my browser.
Yeah.
Tell me about that.
And I have, um, I have a little script that I wrote.
I call it PI hack and it's just like a bunch of little shortcuts, um, that'll tie back
in the basically just be like aliases to other modules or maybe like little definitions that
call a function within a module.
And they'll, they'll do things like I have one for hex encoding, uh, base 64 encoding and
decoding just on like literally the keyword B64D.
So I'll type B64D.
I'll call it.
And then I use a module called Piper clip, which is a, it's a cross OS, uh, clipboard reading
and writing module.
So you just import from Piper clip, import, copy and paste.
And then those are two functions that you can call to copy and paste to your clipboard.
So I'll do B64D paste, and then it'll print out whatever, you know, basic for, or I'll do
copy B64D paste, and then it'll recopy whatever decodes.
And I I'll chain those together very similar to what you're doing, but I'll just do it in
Python.
Yeah, no, that's great.
I was wondering what IPython was because I use Python a lot, but I don't, I, you know,
I grew up writing Python, so I always just write it in a script and run it instead of
using some of these like IDEs.
So, I mean, is that just an IDE for Python?
No, so IPython, it's a, it's basically a, uh, it's a REPL, right?
It's just like an interactive, um, Python console.
It's a Jupyter notebook, essentially.
Um, so you have access to like, you know, the percent, um, like Jupyter, uh, type notebook
type, uh, macros and stuff.
So it's like, yeah, okay.
Yeah, but it's like, it's syntax highlighted, like new lines.
It's like a Python console, but like functional, you know, it's like usable.
It has like, you know, syntax highlighting and suggestions and dropdowns and like colors.
And yeah, so it's like, it's really nice.
Good stuff.
Yeah.
I might have to check that out at some point.
I, I, I think a lot of it's, you know, just kind of on muscle memory for me already, but
I could, you know, integrate this seamlessly.
Yeah.
Really helpful.
I mean, it's just like typing, right?
You find whatever works for you.
And then if, if you can do that faster than what makes sense to like relearn it, then listen.
What are you, what are you saying, Joel?
Are you trying to like shit on the people that know how to like actually type here?
No, what I'm saying, I'm saying like, whatever works for you people that don't type with the,
whatever works for you, Hey, if you could do it as fast or faster that don't even bother
relearning it.
Cause it's probably not worth it.
Yeah, no, that makes sense.
Um, so definitely cool thing there.
Keyboard shortcuts.
Um, all right, let's talk about the command line tools.
Um, so like inside of the base set, um, let's see, what, what is the overlap here?
We've both got said, we've both got Ock, said, Ock, JQ, grep, grep, of course, the trusty
old database, grep.
Yeah, grep.
Yeah.
Okay.
Grep, obviously searching strings, you know, it's just like, you know, you need to search
something within something else grep.
Okay.
If you want to do it with regex, you, you can either use e grep or you can use RG, which
is rip grep, which is like rip grep is amazing.
Yeah.
You put that on your list.
I probably should have put it on my list, but it's a rip grep.
It's, I mean, you can look at the speed tests, the benchmarks and stuff, but it's great.
It's way faster.
It's grep.
It's written in rust.
It's insanely fast.
It has tons of features.
Uh, if I'm searching anything remotely large, I'm using a rip grep because it's way faster.
Joel and I recently used this to just search entire file systems.
Yeah.
We pull the file system off of a device and then literally just rip grepped across the
whole file system for a specific text.
One little tip when you are using that, don't forget the dash a parameter, um, so that it
doesn't ignore binary files.
Just like with grip, but so yeah, um, rip grep, super awesome.
Less top head cut, you know, it's just like, you know, things to view, uh, large buffers
of text without taking up your entire terminal or to search within them.
There's a lot of different tools that do a lot of very similar things that are built into
Linux, um, like head and top FZF, FZF fuzzy find.
So FZF, it's an, it's an awesome tool.
It's like an extension.
I think you like install it in your, in your shell.
Uh, but basically it adds two main things, control R and control T.
Okay.
I think you've mentioned this before.
Yeah.
I think we talked about this maybe off, off air, but, um, basically like if you use control
R in your terminal, it'll let you reverse search through your batch history and fuzzy,
uh, fuzzy find basically extends upon that.
So it, it lets you fuzzy find through your batch history.
So if you don't exactly type the exact command, it will still search and it'll still show you
suggestions that roughly match basically getting fuzzier as it goes up and you can do the same
thing for files on the file system.
So if in your current folder, you just control T or you type FZF, it'll do the same exact fuzzy
search, but for files within your current folder.
Um, so that's really useful for like, in, uh, in VS code.
Exactly.
Yep.
Control P is your command palette or your, your, uh, file switcher and visual studio code.
Very, very similar.
It's really awesome.
I use it multiple times a day, every single day.
Um, in conjunction with that ZSH, uh, that's my preferred shell.
Uh, I use bash for a while.
It's pretty good.
I like ZSH more.
I don't really know why.
I think it's just more customizable.
I think it's more friendly.
I especially use, oh, my ZSH, uh, as, as a, you know, it's basically just like a, uh,
a plugin, like module thing that sits on top of it that makes it easier to add extensions.
And then I use power level 10 K as my theme.
Nice.
Yeah.
No, that's awesome.
I think those are all really essential lists there.
I know we're just kind of rattling them off, but we should probably like just throw them
into the description just so people can know, you know, what kind of command line tools they
need to know.
This will be one of those things you're going to want to like sit at your computer.
You're going to, we're going to read one word, pause, go search it, like check it out, read
another word or yeah, well, and we'll try and put a whole list of the links in the, in
the show notes as well.
Solid.
Okay.
So this is the, I've got two more things here and, uh, one of them kind of flows into
the, into the report.
So I'll talk about this one first.
So, um, my life changed one day, uh, in when, when was it?
Hold on.
Let me see if I can, it was the, at the, I could, the poster's right over there.
Unfortunately, I'm blind, so I can't see it, but it was in London.
Um, I want to say it was 2019 sitting down there with Tom, Nom, Nom and, uh, Stoke at
a live hacking event and they recorded this video.
And before they recorded this video, I was sitting at this table with them.
Um, and essentially in the video, which I'll link, I'll link, I keep on saying the video,
but, uh, uh, it's a video about Tom, Nom, Nom and Stoke, uh, explaining bash for hackers
pretty much.
Um, and one of the main things that, that Tom shows in this is like how to use Vim as a tool
to manipulate input.
And we were kind of talking about like how, if you get the output from a tool and it's
super large, these, all these tools like, you know, uh, head and, and less and top and,
and more and those sorts of things that allow you to manipulate, you know, and not show the
whole buffer on your screen and just, you know, bomb your terminal.
Well, you can just pipe this stuff into Vim dash and it just throws it into a Vim buffer.
And then, you know, you can just execute additional commands by just, uh, doing percent bang and
you can just chain commands together and all of it's just in a Vim buffer and you can search
through it easily.
And it's just so, so, so nice.
Um, and so really I, I just, this one, this one video, um, that, that, um, Stoke and Tom
Nam Nam put together changed my efficiency on the command line for the rest of my life.
Like I'm still making gains on efficiency from this.
And, uh, so definitely learn how to use Vim properly, um, to, to, you know, limit your,
your buffer that you're seeing and chain it through different commands.
Yeah.
I mean, Vim is one of those tools.
I learned how to use it back in college.
It was something I was super like averse to originally.
Yeah.
I was like a hardcore nano user, you know, like it's always, it's like, it's a battle.
It's an oxymoron, like hardcore nano user.
Hardcore nano user.
Yeah.
There, I don't think there really are hardcore nano users.
Let's be honest.
Yeah.
Right.
So, um, I, I tried out Vim and the thing about Vim, it's one of those things that as you
learn, the more that you learn, the easier it gets.
Okay.
Things you're going to notice patterns that are very common.
Uh, Vim was written by programmers.
So it's like, it's very systemic and logical.
You just have to understand the logic systems that they're using.
Right.
It's just like programmers as most programs are.
Yeah.
You'll be like, why do like, why if I press like H, J, K, L that, well, because touch typing,
right?
It's like, you have to think about like, you know, and then if you understand the reasoning
behind it, it makes more sense.
So a lot of Vim, it can be confusing at first, but if you take a little bit of time and you
understand the underlying reasons, it'll make a lot more sense and it'll make your workflow
significantly faster.
There are, you're going to learn like little key binds, for example.
Okay.
Here's one.
Uh, if you're going to, uh, exit a file, most people do either colon, uh, WQ or maybe
colon W then colon Q.
I am one of those people.
Yes.
If you do colon lowercase X, it will write if it needs to and exit.
No, you've got to be kidding me.
Colon lowercase X.
Hold on.
Just colon X.
Yep.
Vim test.txt.
Blah, blah, blah, blah, lowercase X.
What the heck?
Yep.
And if there's no changes, it doesn't write.
Vim X makes perfect sense.
It's the thing you click on up in the corner anyway.
Yeah, it does both.
So that's like a super, I love that one.
I use that one all the time.
Another one, um, this is like really verbose, but, um, basically if you're, if, if you've
been in this situation where you're editing a file and you're about to save it and you
realize I'm in read only mode or I'm, I didn't run this with pseudo and I don't want to remake
these changes.
Tell me right now, man.
It's colon W space bang pseudo T percent.
Okay.
What?
And it basically, it writes it and then it, it runs pseudo T as a command and it pipes it,
it pipes it back in and then it'll be like, do you want to reload the file?
And then you load it and you're good.
Wait, wait, wait.
But what if you're in a directory that doesn't like you can't write?
Uh, you would have to have pseudo.
Does it write it to like a temp buffer or something?
I mean, you could change where it writes to instead of giving it percent.
You could just like, okay, I'm sorry.
We need to do, I need to do this right now.
So, so Vim, so, okay.
So let's say pseudo Sue.
All right.
I'm hopping into root.
I'm changing this.
I'm, I'm changing the, uh, permissions on this file test.
And then I'm jumping out of root and try to write as test here.
Can I write?
Okay.
No, I messed up my permissions.
You know what?
I'm not even going to do this on air.
Joel, we have to, you have to.
Yeah.
Okay.
So basically all you have to know is that call it, like if you do colon W and then after
that you do like space exclamation point cat, for example, it will pipe, it'll write the
current buffer to, it'll pipe it to that command.
Okay.
So it would be like, if you have all the stuff in a file and you like did W exclamation cat,
it would pipe the stuff from the file into cat.
Okay.
So similarly, you can pipe that into pseudo T, like the T command, T E to append stuff to
a file.
Right.
And percent in Vim is the current, is the file name that's associated with the buffer.
So you're saying pipe the current buffer into pseudo T file name.
And then that's how you're actually writing it with pseudo.
And then after you write that, Vim will be like, Hey, the file was modified.
Do you want to reload it?
And you'll click yes.
And then it'll have your changes there.
And then you can just quit.
No way.
Okay.
Hold on.
I've got my, I've got, I've got my test environment up, so I can't write.
It says read only.
And I pipe it into pseudo T.
Percent.
Yep.
And that'll be your current file.
If you don't have a file, then you could just put your file where percent is.
What the heck?
My life has changed.
Pretty dope.
Dude, I run into this issue all the time.
That makes so much sense.
I don't know why I didn't.
Because I always, what I always end up doing is end up like pseudo, or I end up writing into
like temp and then like getting out, pseudoing, then copying it from temp back to where it is.
This happens all the time when I'm trying to modify my, my Apache, uh, you know, configuration.
Yeah.
You forget to run it with pseudo.
You make a bunch of changes and then you got to undo and start over.
It's super annoying.
Wow.
Life-changing, life-changing things being dropped on this episode, man.
Yeah.
I think we need to just sit down sometime and like, I just need to like, Joel, tell me things
that I don't know about the technologies that I use every day because that is, that is really
helpful.
Okay.
Um, okay.
Yeah.
We're at like an hour 10.
Dude, there is no short episode with us.
There really is.
No, I mean, this one is like really hard because there's like so much nuance to all these tools
and I think it's, it's important to understand, um, like the thing that I explained with Vim,
right?
Like that, that is a perfect example of understanding like what you're doing, right?
Instead of just like blindly, like copy pasting, like colon W, right?
Like what is it doing?
Oh, it's writing the buffer.
It's piping it into a command.
It's using T percent means the file name.
Now I get it.
Now I could do that for anything else.
I could change it with other commands.
I can, you know, use this functionality anytime I run another Vim command.
So you just have to understand the fundamentals and then that, that, that really helps a lot.
That's great.
Um, okay.
So I'm going to jump into the next one and then I'm going to take that right into the
report section.
So the next one that I wanted to talk about was DNS chef.
Uh, this is a tool that, uh, Mr. Tux racer, uh, introduced to me a while back.
Um, it's essentially a tool that allows you to just kind of run a DNS server on the fly and
you can like spoof DNS records.
You can, uh, get DNS callbacks.
So like, for example, if you're trying to do a DNS callback, that doesn't go through
collaborator, um, then you can do it through, um, DNS, just like set your own domain, set
your VPS as the authoritative name server for that, you know, section of your domain, spin
up DNS chef, run it on port four or, uh, on port 53.
And then you'll get the, the DNS callback there.
And, um, so I was trying to find some reports that were using some of the tools here.
And obviously a lot of the tools that we're talking about here are just kind of workflow
tools.
They're not, it's like all my reports.
use these tools, like I use Vim all the time.
Exactly.
Vim is in every single report that I write.
No.
Um, but DNS chef was one of the ones that actually like had a pretty tangible result.
And, um, it was a pretty weird program that I reported a bug to with this.
And essentially what the program wanted to do was they wanted to check and see whether we
could establish a reliable, um, reverse shell or, uh, uh, reliable shell of any kind, um,
inside of their VDI environment that they had set up.
Um, and there was a very stringent set of rules for like, uh, the servers you could communicate
with over HDP, HD and HTTPS.
So it was kind of tricky and we found a couple of ways to do it.
Um, tip, there's a proxy that you can use inside of Google.
So if any of the Google services you are using, you can use translate to, uh, the Google translate
service to, uh, open up a page inside of Google translate.
You're taking me back to like computer hacking when I was like a preteen.
Exactly.
This is like how you get around your school.
Yeah, exactly.
The, the, the web filter.
Exactly.
So that was one way that we were able to do it.
Um, another way we were able to do it was, uh, by a DNS shell.
And instead of using like some of the, all this crazy stuff out there, I said, you know
what, I'm going to take five minutes.
It ended up taking like two hours, um, to write my own little DNS shell here, but it would
have taken a lot longer if DNS chef wasn't around because, um, it just makes it really easy
to hook into, uh, if you read the code, uh, it's, there's a pretty clear spot to hook into
it and handle a, um, TXT request, uh, a DNS TXT request.
Um, and, and so I just wrote like a little 20 line client on the client side that like
pings the server for a command, runs the command, gets the output, hex encodes it, and then sticks
it in a DNS request back out to my server, um, and made, made that little, um, you know, reverse
DNS reverse shell, uh, within Python and that fulfilled the requirements and got it, got us
the bounty for, um, you know, establishing a reliable shell outside of their VDI environment.
Um, so I think sometimes the takeaway here is just kind of like, you gotta, you know, Joel,
I know you're an avid listener of my first million as well.
Um, love that podcast.
Um, but one of the things they say on there is just do cool shit, you know, like just find
the stuff that's cool and then do that.
Right.
And then do it.
Yeah.
And, uh, I think this was one of those things for me that was just kind of like, okay, I
would like to be able to write a DNS, you know, reverse shell, um, in, in Python.
And so took some time, did it, got the cool bounty for it.
And I always try to go down those routes whenever I see these goals that people set up.
Uh, we talked about, for example, um, breaking out of root detection.
Like you, you know, that that's going to be possible because you control the app with
Frida.
So you should always be able to break out of, uh, you know, root detection.
So doing something like that and doing something like this, uh, where they like guarantee bounties
for things that you know are possible.
Um, you know, just go and do it.
And it gets you a lot more deeper understanding of some of these things that you know are, are
possible on the border.
So, yeah, yeah.
I, I think it's like that perfect, perfect combination between like CTF kind of like
hack the box, like training type of stuff and real world, like get a bounty for what you're
doing because it's, it's, you're combining real world with the challenge, right?
Like you see the challenge, all you have to do solve the challenge, right?
Okay.
Well, you have, you know, the constraints you're within this environment, figure a way out.
So for sure.
Yeah.
I love those types of things.
Same.
And, and yeah, that mixes well with your puzzler, puzzler.
Yeah.
That tickles my puzzle brain really hard.
Um, all right, man.
I think that's, that's it.
Um, I guess I know we were planning on talking about some, some hardware hacking stuff at the
end of this episode, but let's push that to a different episode.
Um, and we'll, you know, more deep, deep dive it.
Cause I've got some really cool like tools you're teaching me how to use like right over here.
And I'm excited to get on the pod and talk about those.
So we'll do that at a different time.
Super awesome.
All right.
Catch you next week.
Sweet.
That's the pod.
See ya.
Yo, thanks for listening to this episode of critical thinking bug bunny podcast.
If you wanted to, you could go over to Twitter at CTP podcast, give us a follow, or maybe
even subscribe at critical thinking podcast on YouTube.
But the thing that would make you the real MVH would be simply just telling your friends
and hacker fellows about the pod.
Word of mouth is one of the biggest ways that podcasts grow.
So spread the word.
Thanks.
See you next week.